it comes from the idea
that you first want to know what
theories exist
and you're not necessarily focused on
the theory of everything you shouldn't
be you should be focused on knowing what
time it is in human history
so this is one of my familiarizing
yourself with the landscape
pardon me so familiarizing yourself with
what's out there
in the physics well there's that but
there's also the question of
you know what would newton have done if
newton had lived in einstein's time
we don't know um
you have to understand this weird
question what time is it because
the only breakthroughs you can make are
the breakthroughs that are available to
you from your time
so you know uh could galileo
have landed a probe on the surface of
titan
no he wasn't in a position to do it um
doesn't matter how brilliant he is so i
happen to think that this
time is the first time that it is barely
possible to get to a theory of
everything
and you know that itself isn't clear but
that's part of my determination my
determination is
that we actually at least as of 1975 or
76
were within striking distance of
finishing the whole thing off
the only problem is that the last move
is the hardest move of all and so
my take is is that by 1975 we were in
reach but the last move is not
as the earlier moves you know there's
i'm sure you're aware freeman dyson and
hawking both thought that girdles and
completeness theorem had something to
say about a fundamental
theory of everything that is to say that
it excludes it
or potentially exclusive do you do you
see girls in completeness theorem
as having anything to do with physical
theories sabine hostenfelder doesn't
think
so for example so there's well it
depends what you mean
i mean i guess the way i would read it
is the following
what is the theory of everything that's
something we haven't even discussed
and i don't even know that you and i
agree on a theory of everything so let
me ask you what is the theory of
everything to you
i'll tell you what what
what i think you think and then i'll
tell you what i what i think so
i believe i heard you describe it as a
theory in which we're no longer looking
for mathematical improvements
though at least open the door for
religious theological
philosophy philosophical progress
however one wants to define progress
okay that's pretty close
okay so pretty close pretty cool okay
and then for me it would be similar
except i'm interested in
consciousness as well now most
physicists probably i'm not even sure if
it includes yourself
but most physicists believe that
consciousness is a
an emergent phenomenon from
fundamentally
material a material substrate
and i'm unconvinced it might be i'm just
unconvinced
and i would like there to be an
explanation of
consciousness or more of an scene you
could either you can have a quantum
gravity
so you can have you can unify them gr
and qm
but that to me isn't in and of itself a
theory of everything i would like more
explanations so
why is there dark matter what is dark
energy why are the fundamental constants
the way they are
and maybe that's asking too much maybe
it's like lee said
least mullen where the constants evolve
and they change
within black holes still that's an
explanation
i'm more interested in
i see it as broader than most people
conceptualize theories of everything
i take the word everything in other
words i take the word everything very
seriously
i i think that's a mistake
please expand um
well i give an analogy that i i'm
partial to which is
a theory of everything is an attempt to
look at chess games being played and to
learn
the complete set of rules of all chess
game
it is not a theory of how to play chess
well
and what can be done inside the game of
chess
okay so when you're trying to come up
with a theory of everything
it's really very restricted you're
trying to come up with
what is the natural mathematical
description
all of the rules that generate the
universe that we see
okay the consequences of those
sure sure let's take this analogy a bit
more a bit farther
then there's the question of why are the
rules the way they are
why are there pieces at all why these
pieces
are those not questions that you think a
theory of everything should answer
there's the rules and why the rules well
look
my standard gambit which nobody ever
picks up on
is that a theory of everything is
effectively a newspaper story with six
questions where and when who and what
how and why where and when is obviously
space and time
which tells you it's the arena in which
things are
taking place the who and the what is
like the equipment and the players
so i would say that i'm going to make
the players into
the fermions the matter and the
equipment
into the bosons the force okay
so you've got now four of your six
questions and then your last two are how
and why i'm going to say how
is the equations and why lagrangian that
generates the equation
now that means that if you don't know
anything about
physics you can remember oh
that guy on the internet said where and
when who and what how and why
and that that's what constitutes a
physical theory
so i would say that that's what i'm
responsible for when i'm trying to give
you
a an understanding of where all of this
comes from